[Applause]
i'm very happy that you sent me so many
video questions
this really is nice and frankly they are
spot-on
so i will answer a few today and i
promise
to answer more soon and i will start
with a question from
valentin hello president vonderlane
the 21st century has many problems that
we are going to have to solve together
but one of the most pressing issues is
that of climate change
what is a european union doing in order
to help minimize the effects of climate
change
in our union and abroad so thank you
very much valentin
i couldn't agree more fighting climate
change is my number one priority
and that's why we have our european
green deal
we want europe to be the first climate
neutral continent by 2050
and for that we have to cut emissions
even more and even faster we need clean
transport
we need more renewable energy sources
like hydrogen
we have to build a circular economy we
have to renovate buildings
and to have a greener agriculture just
to name a few of the things
that we need to do indeed last week
we proposed to cut at least 55 percent
of emissions over the next
10 years this is quite a step
but i'm deeply convinced we can do it
and you valentin
and your generation expect us to be bold
and quick
on climate change and we'll do all in
our power to deliver
and now i take a question from marco
dear president my question is the
following how long
can we still tolerate the disrespect of
lgbt rights by countries inside
european union like poland and hungary
thank you very much thank you very much
for this question marco
listen every person in europe should be
free to be who they are
and love who they want in all european
countries
and discrimination on the basis of
sexual orientation has
absolutely no place in the european
union
and whenever it is in my power i will
act against it
including the suspending of distribution
of funds
and by bringing governments to court
and one more thing i will push for
mutual recognition
of family relations in the european
union because if you are a parent in one
country
you are a parent in every country
so marco you can count on me to promote
a union of equality
and right now we are working on an
lgbtqi
equality strategy i will present it soon
so stay tuned and
now i will take a question from julia
dear president young people all over
europe are suffering the economic
consequences of the pandemic
in july eurostat published the 2020
statistics of youth unemployment in the
european union
17 of young people all over europe are
currently unemployed
and that number rises up to almost 42
in spain the country where i come from
young people
are worried about our careers and our
futures so my question is the following
what is the european commission going to
do to tackle youth unemployment in the
european union
thank you gracias thank you julia
youth unemployment is indeed a problem
in europe and
the corona virus has made it worse
i'm very sad about this and not only at
the politician but also at the mother
and i will fight to create jobs for
young people
indeed the european union is helping
with
youth employment support this means 22
billion euros for
vocational training for instance
and this is new skills and new jobs for
young people
and there's more you know that we have
this massive program of 750 billion
euros
we call it next generation eu this will
create
jobs jobs jobs especially in the green
and in the digital
economy so as difficult as the situation
is dear julia
i am confident that if we stand together
things will improve now
kunti has a question for me
[Music]
so that was fun and i'm already looking
forward to our next chat
so keep sending me questions and see you
soon